this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality best-selling
author launching his brand new book
today own your past
change your future
it's book launch day at ramsey we're a
little jacked up around here to say the
least open phones again triple eight
eight two five five two two five you can
call in we help people build wealth we
help them do work that they love and we
help you create amazing relationships
and mental wellness thanks for being
with us any questions around any of that
we're here to help you the phone number
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
john the book is out in the wild it is
out in the wild how's it feel it's good
it's good to
be able to see the people starting to
get the audiobook and or the writing me
back chapter by chapter i loved it i
loved it it was good so it's been it's
been a good day it's been good good yeah
it's fun you've been doing a ton of
media today yes you were here with me
before before god himself before the sun
got hurt yeah that's right yeah we were
doing stuff early and uh it's good it's
good a lot a lot of uh media attention
because a lot of folks out there
uh it's a word i picked up from craig
groschel's podcast this week or um
the last two years have depleted yeah
people yep and they need to be
replenished this is a phrase he's using
and i like that um
that that you know the thing we didn't
see coming was we held our breath and
gritted our teeth and pushed through all
the stress around the pandemic all the
different things that came at you
regarding that whether it was medical
stress financial stress career stress
all of it came at you real estate stress
now you got inflation yeah now you got
everything else and your tank's empty
that's right
so if you think of life like a like we
like we talked about on the show you've
got to have an emergency fund you got to
have some money set aside so when things
get bonkers in the last two years we
gritted our teeth and burned through all
of our margin and then the world went
bananas right when we were coming out of
this thing right inflation went crazy
the war kicks off and then people act in
the fool so um yeah you just look around
and everybody's spent man yeah and it's
a dif you know
and you know sometimes they're
translating that to uh i'm burnt out on
my marriage and they weren't they're
just burnt out i talked to a teacher
yesterday on my show saying i i love
teaching i love the kids i love art
i think i'm done with with this job
though and as i dug into it no man she
was just depleted she's just exhausted
yeah you got to pull something back into
the tank now
fill back up yeah
and game on again that's right that's
right but you got to be fill up you
can't be game on without being filled
back up and that's one of the things
this book is going to do so beautifully
for a lot of you it had that effect on
me when i read it uh because i'm like
anybody else our adrenaline game yeah
you ran hard man man i've been going
this two years has been wide freaking
open
and i had a thousand people that were
depending on us to keep revenue coming
in here to keep payroll so they could
keep their jobs so we had to you know
you're spent from doing that and um
actually craig and i were talking about
this we're friends and then he goes and
puts this on his leadership podcast and
it just really resonated with me i sent
it i sent his podcast out to all our
leaders because it's just but own your
past change your future is one of the
ways to put fuel back in your tank a not
so complicated approach to relationships
mental health
wellness
some of the things you've been feeling
where you thought you were like
i'm really not right uh well you
probably aren't yeah but that's okay
actually
that feeling means you are right yeah
because you should be having anxiety
it's an alarm bell yeah um and
i had a conversation with a a mental
health practitioner who's much more
accomplished and is brilliant um
and we both got to talking and you know
what dave the the and i'm speaking as a
member of this community
the last hundred years the mental health
community has convinced us that all of
our problems are quote unquote in our
head and if we can just think the right
thought then we can figure it out and
then everything will be okay and
i think that's completely inaccurate i
think there are seasons when i just have
to go do
and i have to go begin acting
differently even if i don't feel like
being nice to my wife i'm gonna go do
the dishes and take the trash out
because i'm gonna help i'm gonna start
leaning into some of these practices and
we've just left that off the
quote-unquote mental health conversation
the relationship conversation and so is
there some stuff we gotta think
differently but man we just gotta start
doing stuff differently sometimes well
and you keep talking about and you warn
me out with it um
in a good way that that the importance
of relationships the importance of
people are your emergency funds yeah
relationships are your emergency fund
when you're facing high stress high
burnout situations or are you facing
high anxiety you're facing grief you're
facing uh catastrophe tragedy whatever
it is you're facing and and we've all
had our share of those things in the
past 36 months
um i don't remember if you if you
remember
um during our interview when you and i
one of the last conversations we had
because of my research my academic work
with leaders and executives
one of the last things i asked you was
who do you listen to and you rattle off
a group of men that you're connected
with a group of pastors here a group of
this and a leadership team and i
remember going to the parking lot and i
called sheila and said dave and i might
disagree on a thousand things but i
trust him and i can work for him because
he's got other people he listens to he's
got the other people in his life and
that i've found is the key to making
good business decisions good financial
decisions good marital decisions is
having other people in your life you can
reach out to yeah
but in this mass i'll be honest with you
i reached a point where i just want to
be around people i did too i found
myself healthy you said you're talking
about forcing yourself to go through the
dishes
it was like i had to force myself back
into those relationships that's right i
had to do it as an act of my will
because i didn't want to do it i didn't
want to be around them that's right i
was just disgusted
human beings pissed me off you know it
was just like yes there was a point
during all this stuff when all the masks
and the vaccines and the crazy butt
stuff and i just went you know what i
don't want to talk to any of you you're
all fools i'm going home you're all full
netflix is just gonna tell me porch
they're gonna tell me what i want to
watch it's a dog by god the dog ain't
got an opinion about the vaccine you
know i don't want anything to do with
all this junk and and uh but you know
there's that's a human reaction
absolutely yes and yet you do need to
take some things where you own that and
you step into
intentionally pass that and you call a
friend and go okay
you know two friends three friends we
got to sit on the back porch and we're
not turning on the tv and we're not
looking at screens
we're just gonna sit here and tell
stupid 13 year old jokes or whatever
we're gonna do but um
but you know we're just gonna hang and
that's the kind of stuff in this book
and that's why this book's quite hot
it's going out it's going out the door
like crazy own your past change your
future a not so complicated approach to
relationships mental health and wellness
if you've listened to the doctor john
deloney show
and he says
uh
things that you go gosh i wish i could
just talk to him i wish i could just sit
down with him
this is uh the best attempt we can all
come up with is this book is just like
him sitting across the table from you if
you got i wonder what he would say about
well just read this book because it's
what he would say to you if you were
sitting across the table and if you're
not listening to dr chandler show the
podcast you need to be you need to be
tuning in so the book is on sale
officially today
uh it is s although all of you that
pre-ordered there's tens of thousands of
you that pre-ordered thank you so much
for that over the past few months all of
those books were shipped uh today
uh they're available today in bookstores
amazon is shipping today if you
pre-ordered there or you ordered a day
it'll ship today if you order from
ramseysolutions.com
it will ship today the audiobook the
e-book are all available as well as read
by the author
um and i'll just tell you that's a treat
hey let me tell you this
no it's not lost on me that none of this
happens without your hospitality i'm
grateful for you wow thank you for all
the help and support this has been a
beautiful journey easy to endorse
something that's this transformative
that's this helpful i'm great and that
this is this good for people
own your past change your future get
your copy today we're gonna be taking
your calls right here on the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dalone ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsey show
i'm dave ramsey the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five charlotte is in denver colorado hi
charlotte how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
so i'm just calling because we are
moving across countries in colorado to
iowa and we've just put our house under
contract and we're getting quite a lot
of proceeds from the sale of our house
and i just want to make sure
we're using that money wisely moving
forward
cool you going to buy a house when you
move
yeah it's where my husband's family is
from so we feel pretty confident about
buying in that area okay good
and why would you not just use this
money to buy a house
so my husband's going back to school i'm
finishing nursing school he's put me
through school for the last two years
and now we're working on his career and
he's going back to school and so the
mortgage payment that we can afford is
going to be a lot less than the house
that we just sold
so we're still planning on we're about
gonna get about a hundred thousand
dollars worth of proceeds um after
closing costs from the sale of our house
we're planning on looking at a house in
the budget of about 150 000 and then
planning on putting about 60 000 down
and we could put more on but we're we're
not sure if we should put money towards
his tuition so we have that piled up
um
kind of doing like doing other stuff we
want to pay off about 19 000 worth of
student loan debt and then um fill up
our um emergency fund so we're done with
the baby sets and i just
make sure that thousand dollars just
feels like that makes sense i like to
make sure we're using it no i think you
pay off the student loan debt you have
the emergency fund you have the money
set aside for his tuition no student
loans no future loans got rid of the old
ones got rid of the new ones
um
you put the rest of it on your house put
the rest of it on your house yeah have
had it and you're gonna go get you're
gonna go past your bar and you're gonna
be a nurse while he's in school that's
cool
yeah wonderful what's he studying oh
donald kate
he's gonna be doing um computer science
um to be a software developer i love it
okay so let me tell you this um
this was a something that actually i've
had the benefit of sitting by dave off
air and just talking to him as my life
has grown up and changed i grew up and
didn't have we didn't have a lot growing
up in fact we had some seasons where
things were pretty sparse and so the
idea of fifty thousand or twenty five
thousand dollars or a hundred thousand
was so overwhelming just
just that number was big
and dave has reminded me just privately
um always go back to the principles and
always go back to the basics right so
whether it's ten dollars a hundred
dollars ten thousand or a hundred
thousand dollars i'm still going to roll
back to those baby steps and i'm going
to just follow those principles line
after line after line and it's just
taking a lot of pressure off me because
i tend to look at the number not at the
ratios tend to look at that number and
not at just the basic principles
that are always going to work whether
it's ten bucks or a ten thousand kelly
it's
what he's saying is actually perfect
because it's human nature when you get
an amount of money
that is the largest amount emotionally
you've ever went oh my god that's a lot
of money you know that kind of thing
right when that happens in your spirit
all of a sudden you think it's so much
money the rules don't apply yeah well
yeah they do
because you're going to go want to buy a
tesla right because
it's like the guy who got a you know he
got a ten thousand he does scratch and
sniff lottery ticket right and got ten
thousand dollars and now he thinks he
can retire you can't return ten thousand
dollars you goob but he never had ten
thousand dollars in his hand before
right and so he goes oh my god i was
alone you know no you didn't you just
got ten thousand dollars it's okay i
mean it's just the principles still
apply the principles still apply and i
you know it the weird thing is you'll
have these emotional moments as you
handle more and more and more wealth to
john's point that will stretch you on
that i mean i remember the first time i
gave
a thousand dollars right in one single
check
i remember it distinctly because we'd
gotten a ten thousand dollar thing that
happened and i was tithing at the church
and i went oh well i'm just a big hairy
deal
you know that's a thousand dollars i
don't know how this place operated
before i came along you know but it's
just like
that a load of crap you know but that's
just what happens that's just the way
you feel because you think that's a lot
of money and then i remember the first
time i tied ten thousand dollars yep you
know and i wasn't nearly as arrogant
about that that's right it was weird hey
dave i had a moment where i was i had a
similar moment when i thought look at
all this i'm giving and i just i'm
friends with my pastor and he's like you
know so and so
she's a widow
and she drops this much money every year
and i thought oh gosh it's just case you
thought
so charlotte that's human nature and so
just remember the principles always
apply there's three things you can do
with money you can give it
you can enjoy it
and you can invest it and you should
always be looking at doing all three
you should always be generous you should
always be saving you should always be
enjoying it and what you outlined there
following the baby steps allows you to
do all of that you're hitting your
education goals you're hitting your move
goal you're hitting your real estate
goal your debt goal everything your debt
goal yeah everything's going right here
yeah and so it worked perfectly uh it
just feels a little bit unnerving
because the first time i had a checkup
that's a normal human reaction
congratulations good for you way to go
it sounds like a great move too kelly's
in virginia beach hi kelly how are you
hi how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up
well i have a settlement for my minor
child after a car accident
that is being held in a low interest
faring account
of the court's choosing
and i want to petition the juvenile
court system for access to the funds
because in three years the account that
they put it in it's only gained nine
dollars oh and she's not going to be 18
until she's six and i just really feel
like something better could be done with
this not risky but better
yeah well you're right the question is
can we get the juvenile court to grow a
brain
uh because they're so scared that the
parent of the child is gonna go out and
use the money for cocaine or lottery
tickets or something stupid that they
that they clamp down on it and they get
dumber than a rock a lot of times
honestly they're the it's the stupidest
thing it aggravates me to no end it's my
freaking child as long as i'm a
responsible adult taking care of my
freaking child i should be able to
invest this money but the court doesn't
see it that way so it's a problem i
would petition it with a financial
advisor
furnishing you a letter
showing that this is the same set of
mutual funds you would put in your 401k
your honor
he says sarcastically but um yeah and
and so and actually juvenile court judge
is a friend of mine i i mess with her
all the time but um but the uh uh but
you know the thing is that
you know but you need to if you go in
and just like like this thing making no
money i want my money that's not gonna
work as a petition right but if you go
in with a really logical
calm conservative plan and these are the
same mutual funds your honor you would
put in into your 401k plan and that's
what we or into a 529 plan if i was
going to a financial advisor so go to
ramseysolutions.com click on smart
vester pro find the smart investor pro
in your area and they will help you
with this
and then you've got at least a shot but
i will tell you that what you're running
into is very normal and it's frustrating
as crud
i've never heard that
i didn't even know that they had
assigned
a liaison until we started getting uh
advertisements from a bank that i knew
myself or her dad didn't have accounts
at
so when i contacted the bank they didn't
even want to they told me that they
weren't at liberty to tell me why they
were sending my daughter advertisements
from their bank
and i had to go to the bank
and physically speak with the manager
and then she finally said well yes we do
have an account here but we can't tell
you what's in it or what's going on with
it you'll have to contact the courthouse
and then it clicked in
oh this must be the settlement money
yeah yeah wow they didn't even let me
know i didn't even this is the
nanny state that has taken over parental
rights wow from the parent is what it
means to in a financial realm and i'm
sure that bank loves sitting on that
kind of money and paying a dollar
of interest a year
yeah they're making a killing on that
money absolutely
wow
i had no idea about that
thanks for sharing that kelly good grief
i didn't know that's how that worked i
love it what a mess i love it
oh my gosh wow
you're not gonna believe what's coming
up after this break i have a friend
who's a celebrity that emailed me a few
minutes ago and he says hey can i can i
uh
can i ask a favor i said sure
and then i just got this scam email back
somebody's hacked him oh fantastic i'm
not going to give his name but we're
going to cover scam emails here coming
back from the break this is the ramsey
show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host
open phones at
825-5225
okay so we do have a debt-free scream on
hold i gotta get to them but you gotta
hear this so
my buddy uh who shall remain nameless uh
is a household name uh uh we
share emails and we'll bug each other
and give each other a hard time
sometimes and he i get this strange
email from a minute ago and it says um
at the commercial break it said hey can
i ask a favor and
uh normally he would say what it was
right but uh i bound back sure anything
you need what do you need i hope any way
i can you know and then i get this email
back sorry for bothering you with this
email i need to get an apple gift card
for my niece it's her birthday but i
can't do this now because i'm currently
traveling i tried purchasing one online
but unfortunately had no luck with that
uh can you get it from any store around
you i'll pay you back as soon as i can
total amount needed is 500 kindly let me
know if you can handle this
so the the the giveaway for me is none
of your friends would say the words
kindly let me know if you can handle
this
well there's that and um
even my most uh
you know uh uh elderly of friends yes
which several would fall in that
category could probably figure out a way
to execute a gift card purchase online
so
this guy could have had like three or
four possible different assistants you
could do it but um
you know it wouldn't have been emailing
me about doing it so i just emailed the
scammer back he's obviously had his
personal email hacked
and so i just flipped it back and
emailed it right back and just said scam
alert so i'm messing with him i should
have kept him pushing it you know sucked
it in i'll be the fbi mole oh i put
james child's email address on there
yeah that was good i could do that i
could put somebody that i want to mess
with kelly's cell phone
no but this guy can help you
[Laughter]
that's the worst punking in the world
turn somebody over to a scammer accident
oh so i guess everybody knows about the
nigerian prince this is the version this
is the new this is the new version of
the nigerian prince nobody knows about
the uh i need an apple gift card for my
niece it's her birthday but i'm so inept
i can't buy it online
however if you'll run down to the store
and buy one physically for me i'll show
up and take it from you as a
representative of your friend oh my god
what are you an idiot just kindly let me
know yeah seriously kindly let me know
kindly let me know i walked kindly i
kindly said no
kinda kinda kindly
jordan and nicole are in washington
they're debt-free way to go guys
thank you
thank you how much did you pay off
we paid off ninety six thousand sixty
three dollars in a little over two years
way to go and your range of income
during that two years
one ten to 120
good what do you guys do for a living
i am a pipe fitter welder and
i am a pediatric nurse awesome
very cool y'all have been busy the last
few years both of you huh we have thank
you very much
what what uh what kind of debt was the
96k
it was our house yeah
talking to weird people
how old are you guys
how old are you i'm 32
and my wife is uh 31. and you have paid
for house
yes sir
straight up weird you won
you just won monopoly right then yeah
wow
you got you got a hotel on boardwalk man
way to go you guys it's amazing
what's this house worth
uh the house is roughly right around 400
000 right now
and it's yours
i like it y'all are freaky cool so tell
me the truth how did all this happen
what got this started
uh really it started about 11 years ago
before we got married uh we we took
financial peace at one of our local
churches and
uh
you know just started kind of working
the program one of the goals through our
marriage was to really maintain debt
free we did do some some davish things
for a lot of years
still we stayed away from credit cards
but
we did do
davish and then
really the last two years
decided to to put the pedal to the metal
and we've looked at the
the debt we owed on the house and said
we could do this in two years
is that what flipped the switch from ish
to knocking out the house was you
realize you could do it
we committed to doing it we committed
yeah well i mean there had to be
something kind of going on usually
there's some kind of an event or some
conversation
it doesn't just generally drop out of
the sky on your head i mean what was the
thing that went from ish to committed
i think for us the one of the biggest
things was
we had our third kiddo
and
we have a three bedroom house
so we were trying to figure out well um
are we going to upgrade and get a bigger
house are we going to just commit and
figure out how to all five of us live in
this house
and so we made some
um made some changes and some
uh sacrifices we actually put his crib
in our walk-in closet and and made it
work so that we all had space and we
could
we could live in this house comfortably
and not have to
um
sacrifice our goal of paying it off so
at that point jordan
made a little um
a list of our goals and there we go
there it is pay off and taped it in our
in our closet and we just started
questioning it you went down to home
depot and looked for a room stretcher
and they didn't have them
they don't have that yeah yeah that's
right i understand that's usually
there's some kind of a series of events
and you go okay instead what we're gonna
do is we're gonna knock this freaking
thing out yeah yeah that's cool that's
very good because the way the
decision-making
process works that brings you up to that
point of committed is an interesting
thing to kind of consider when you're
considering transforming your life
because you freaking transformed your
lives way to go
thank you thank you what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
i
personally think just having a plan and
then working the plan um was our key you
know we we had that direction we knew
what we wanted
um and then
you know we went after it by working
extra um cutting back where we could
uh
you know doing the the budget on a
monthly
basis and having those conversations and
saying no
the three young kids which can be
definitely hard
but
that was the key for us i think
i think it's important
for everybody to hear
you guys could have done what most
people would do in your situation which
is to put your house in the market and
go buy a bigger house that you probably
couldn't afford and i want you to know i
think you did the greatest thing you
could have done for those kids which is
to keep everybody crammed together but
to let them see you struggle pay this
thing off and now they're going to get
to live a life with infinitely less
stress because mom and dad are not going
to be running around trying to figure
out how to make bills work they're going
to be figuring out how how we're going
to spend and save and give this money
away right what an incredible
transformation
yeah thank you well done you guys are
heroes
with it too they know they know that we
were we've been paying off our house and
especially our oldest is six and
he's um he knows no credit cards and
he'll see the commercials and say
they're lying
excellent it's pretty cool to have their
involvement yeah excellent he sees a
sofa commercial he starts going cheetah
yeah i like it that's great i'm so proud
of you man that's incredible
pretty much
pretty much that's cool i like it man
let's train them early
[Laughter]
way to go you guys way to go we got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
how ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth how you can too you're on your
way to being millionaires with a paid
for
400 000
house and 120 000 income and not a
payment in the world and you're only 32.
wow
i love it also copy a total money
makeover count it down jordan and nicole
from washington 96 000 paid off in two
years making 110 to 120 house and
everything let's hear your debt-free
scream
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
and the chipmunk voices are joining in
there that's good love it kiddos are
even in on the dead free scream this is
how it's done right here boys and girls
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well it's book launch week for own your
past change your future dr john dolone's
first major publication a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness the
importance of connection
uh the importance of dealing with the
things that are in your past not being
defined by them
learning to tell the story to yourself
properly and into the future it's a
whole different thing
you're going to need this book it's now
available right now everyone needs to
read it it is not a book for crazy
people
if you have serious mental illness you
are going to need something different
than this book
or more than this book anyway it won't
hurt you
but it's not about uh it's not about
dealing with major major
diagnosis of uh multiple personality
disorder it's not that's not what this
book is about this book is about the
rest of us who all have a journey and if
you had to have a good guide
on your journey this is the book right
this is the guy you want dr john deloney
it's only 20 bucks at
ramseysolutions.com
we're going to be doing two book
signings john's going to be in two
different cities this week he'll travel
to phoenix arizona and on thursday night
of this week at 6 00 p.m april the 21st
he'll be at the barnes noble at desert
ridge marketplace at north tatum
boulevard up on the north side of
phoenix it's a great store i've been
there myself he'll be signing books
starting at six o'clock make plans to
attend
dallas texas a week from this wednesday
the next week after the book comes out
wednesday april the 27th at 6 pm the
barnes and noble there at preston wood
town center on beltline road again i've
been there and done a signing myself and
it's a wonderful store so make sure you
make plans to come out to those two
different signings dallas and phoenix
and other than that you're more than
welcome always to drop by and watch the
show here uh dr john's signing books at
the break just now during the commercial
break out here in the lobby we've always
got 50 to 200 folks hanging out out here
with the free coffee and the free
homemade good chocolate chip cookies
made by satan i mean made by
she's not satan no
she's a tempter she's a tempter that's
what she is yeah so the chocolate chip
cookies you smell them when you walk
into our lobby smells like mama's home
instead of a corporate america yeah so
come in hang out the lobby in the whole
uh visitor center here at ramsey's worth
seeing in franklin tennessee come and
make that a stop and john i'll be happy
to sign your books if he's in town hey
we're gonna cause a ruckus at those uh
those those sports book signings they've
never had mosh pits there we're gonna
get them going we're gonna have a good
time at this mosh pit book signing we're
gonna have a good time man
not one i've tried nope i've done just
about everything and that's good
we're gonna have a good time all right
guatemala is calling jeff is on the line
hi jeff welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave and john thank you for taking my
question sure um so my wife and daughter
and i have lived in guatemala for the
last five years as missionaries and
non-profit directors
we're now making a transition
in careers and i've been accepted into a
flight school to become an airline pilot
is in phoenix
so the big transition um we're currently
on baby steps four five and six
and our question is we actually own a
home in colorado that we have been
renting for the past
five years
and we thought about selling this home
and buying a phoenix but we were talking
to our cpa
and found out that because we haven't
lived in the home
uh two of the last five years that we
are going to be paying an estimated 54
thousand dollars in capital gains yep
and so we just want to get your advice
on
if we should keep renting it out um
and then are we just keep renting in
phoenix and then hope that
years later we can maybe eventually make
that place our primary residence again
and but it's also a hard decision too
because with the airline industry
we don't know where we will be living in
the next three years or five years what
do you owe on the house in colorado
about 163 000 and what is it worth
about 450 i would sell it
pay the capital gains put the money in
the bank go to flight school how are you
paying for flight school
um we've been saving for
years until we have enough to cash flow
it very very good so i would go to
flight school and when you know where
you're going to be based
and you move your family to where you're
going to be based after you graduate
from flight school i would buy a home
okay and just put just park the money in
a in a money market account or in a
little uh
you know uh s p 500 mutual fund or
something but
here's the thing you have
your family's going through a tremendous
amount of transition
you're moving from missionary
to the to commercial pilot you are
moving from guatemala right to phoenix
the last thing you need is a tenant
in another state
okay
and and the capital gains is not going
to get any better and you're not ever
going to move back in that house
you're not going to be based out of
colorado with a major airline
right the likelihood is close to zero
that's that is true um
yeah that is true yeah so let's just
call it tap out take your money
while while the getting is good it's a
great real estate market let's get the
money out and call it a day baby thank
you for serving the lord man it's an
interesting transition you've been
through
thank you so um if we were gonna like
maybe buy in five years would you
suggest putting that money
in something more than a money market
account yeah i like parking it in an s p
500 because you're going to be leaving
it alone quite a while it may not be
quite five years right but an s p 500
right you know it's a
no load fund so there's going to be no
commission
like vanguard's got a good one as an
example okay there's lots of them but
that's you know fidelity's got one
there's two or three of them you can get
it's no commission and you just park it
there and it's you know if even if it
does poorly it's gonna do better than a
stupid savings account
correct yeah correct i mean let's say
you put let's say you put 200 000 in
there and it loses
a horrible amount it's the worst
four-year period in a long long time and
you lose 10 percent of your money which
by the way if you look up statistically
that would be a very rare event but if
you did you lost 20 grand yeah whatever
life goes on
yeah you already lost 54 because the
stupid government took it so you know i
mean it's just like
that you know that's what you're dealing
with so
was i unclear
okay
good stuff good times gabriel is in
orlando florida hey gabriel welcome to
the ramsey show
hey how are you guys better than i
deserve how can i help
well thanks for taking the call i just
have a quick question so i run a
business and you know we're a debt-free
company good i've been around for 16
years good and um i guess the main
question that i have i can't find the
answer to how do you budget
companies like budgeting when you don't
know
you know what next month is going to
bring in
well you do know
you've been doing this 16 years you got
a pretty good idea
okay don't you i mean you ought to be
able to tell me you gotta be able to
tell me what the next 12 months look
like pretty solid if you've been doing
it 16 years this ain't your first ride
on the cabbage truck
it's true i'm just trying to figure out
like you know every year it changes
though like sure it does exactly yeah so
here's what you're doing it's a
forecasting method and you say okay
based on what we did last year
then the coming 12 months or the coming
three months or the coming march or the
coming april or the coming may whatever
it is
we should do something similar to what
we did last may
but it could be better
because of a b or c
or it could be worse because of x y or z
and then you make the adjustment because
of that okay
so here's an example okay we are
launching dr john delony's book this
year
in this month
so when we get to this month next year
to do our budget for our publishing
department
we're not going to have probably a book
this big in the apr in april of 2023
and so we're going to have to go oh we
can't budget the same revenue because
we're not going to have a book that
sells this much in this month we might
have another book that sells as much in
may but we're not going to in april
likely next year so by the way next year
april budget's already done and it's not
got a book in it so that's the truth
that's what happened okay so that's what
you're doing you adjust down for things
that are different
up for things that are different and
then you have your projected revenues
same thing with your expenses you adjust
down for things that are different and
up for things that are different and now
you've got your adjusted expenses based
on same month last year same year
last year
and then you have an adjusted profit and
loss and after doing it 16 years you
should hit within a 90 percentile within
10 percent of accuracy on that
that puts us hour the ramsey show on the
books
[Music]
hey it's john dolone co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today it is book launch day at ramsey
own your past change your future is
officially on the market you will find
it in bookstores today you will have it
shipped to your home today if you were
one of the tens of thousands that
pre-purchased it the audiobook is
available the e-book is available own
your past change your future a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness now available
everywhere great books are sold
including ramsey solutions.com on our
own store only 20 bucks available right
this second open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create amazing relationships
and mental wellness and dr john's hair
here to help with that part in
particular today triple eight eight two
five five two two
five ryan's with us in tampa florida hi
ryan welcome to the ramsay show
hey guys how are you today better than
we deserve brother what's up
um quick question for y'all
i
my wife and i are recently debt free
except for our house we paid off about
50 000 in student loans way to go um
thank you
we've got about three months worth of
expenses saved in the emergency fund
we're going to try to get closer to six
months but my question is that
when is the right time
now when do i really need a financial
advisor you know we both got
raw 401ks with our company and i've gone
in and
selected
the
the funds that look like they've been
doing the best over 10 years
so outside of that you know when do we
really need
to get a financial advisor you got kids
no not yet okay all right
well anytime you're going to do any more
investing you're certainly going to need
the one uh to you know just if you need
to do something more than your 401k or
different than your 401k
and if you're ready to start 529 for a
kiddo that's why i ask about kiddos then
you can do that if you want to meet with
a smart investor pro now they'll meet
with you
you know and they'll tell you exactly
what's going on and you may not have a
need to purchase a fund from them right
now
but it's okay to start establishing a
relationship because
they definitely want you know they
definitely want to be available to you
um
they make their money based on what you
invest with them if you're investing
zero with them
um then you know you don't have a lot of
need for one right now
but uh uh and they don't have a lot of
need for you
but
uh but you know that so that that's you
know you don't need a real estate agent
if you're not buying a list buying or
selling a house right
uh but it's not doesn't hurt if you're
thinking about getting into you know
thinking about buying a house sometime
the next year or two doesn't hurt to
meet with one that kind of thing that's
that's the way this works and so
yeah you know uh if you want to hit
ramseysolutions.com and click on that
that's a it's a good thing
john there's a a huge advantage um in
the multitude of counsel
there's safety
the bible says and so putting people in
your corner that are experts in
different areas subject matter experts
whether it's taxes or estate planning or
insurance or
mental health or
investing
it is a good thing in every one of those
cases
including mental health professionals
they are there to teach you right
not to um
not not to boss you right and so uh you
you never want to say
financially oh i can't do that my
financial advisor won't let me that's
absolute crap it's your freaking money
yes
uh my financial advisor advised me
against it and i agreed with his advice
once i understood would be a proper way
of stating that and i just got a call i
think i just got a call from my um
financial advisor the other day who's uh
one of the ramsey trusted advisors and
he said hey this is what the market's
doing i'm recommending that we make this
thing here's why i'm recommending we
make this thing what is what are your
thoughts on this and i said well
my response was are you making the same
deal on your personal thing and he said
absolutely yes and i said i understand
why you're doing this i trust you i
trust this process so let's let's do
what we're gonna do but there's somebody
who
all they're doing all day is watching
this stuff on my behalf right because i
might know the basics i might understand
what's happening i don't have time to go
in that's why that's why they're that's
why i hire them right so having an
expert is so important absolutely
absolutely daniel is with us in dayton
ohio hi daniel what's up
afternoon sir good to talk to you you
too how can we help
well so i've got a question my wife and
i are considering leading
uh financial peace at our church this
coming summer wonderful right um
we're just in them
about baby steps to looking to have the
car
uh paid off this week house in for the
five years or so
um and just looking for like
uh we've been following you for our
whole married life about six years
but i'm just concerned with who's trying
to lead the cat class while we are in
the middle
of the steps ourselves just uh just kind
of either encouragement advice or
caution that you may have with trying to
do that no i would do it absolutely 100
absolutely i'll do it
um as long as you're doing the stuff we
teach
you don't want to be a hypocrite
why is it taking you six years
that's just the long end of the spectrum
um that's your mortgage too right yeah
is that your mortgage yeah
yes okay well baby step two doesn't have
your mortgage in it man
well i'm i just think long term though
didn't you tell me you had been working
on this six years
no my wife we've been listening to you
following you and then we bought our
house a couple of years ago and then so
yeah by the time we are free and clear
of everything would be in the next three
to six years house and everything
working bonuses yes sir okay i'm talking
i thought you said you were in baby step
two
are you in baby step two
yes we have our thousand dollars and we
are working on
uh the rest of our debts okay so how
much debt did you have not counting your
home
uh we had we have a we had a personal
one
of about twelve thousand and then so you
have not been working on baby step two
for six years
no he said they're going no he said he'd
been following our stuff for six years
we've been listening to you not really
yeah
okay
all right you've been listening at me
okay i got it okay so when did you
actually start working on the baby steps
uh about a year and a half ago okay
there we go better now yes
please take financial peace university
what i was trying no what i was trying
to ascertain daniel i was trying to
figure out if you were issuing this or
not if you're sort of kind of doing it
because if you're going to go in and be
a hypocrite you don't want to lead it
because the i'm telling you you'll have
a hardcore dave fan in there hardcore
ramsey fan in there and they'll call
your butt out man so as long as you're
really doing the stuff as long as you're
really doing this stuff you'll be a
great coordinator it doesn't matter what
baby step you're in but just don't be
don't be hypocritical that's what i was
trying to dig into how you doing this
six years near baby step two still so
that didn't make sense but i now
understand you just started really
actually applying the concepts that
you'll be leading in financial peace
about a year ago that's perfect you're
gonna be a great coordinator thank you
for doing it and yes you should do it
please thank you thank you please
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i got to tell you we are so excited
about the new book on your past change
your future came out today another thing
we're really excited about a lot of good
things happening around here right now
we're back on the road again we've got
these live events showing up everywhere
and uh including we have launched our
first smart conference in several years
the pandemic and the offset with the
venues and man it was just been a mess
and man we're so excited to get to be
with you all we've got 6 000 seats we've
sold over half of them already for the
dallas smart conference this fall
october the 22nd it's all day long
saturday it is all
of the ramsey personalities plus special
guests craig and amy grochelle from lot
lifechurch.tv that uh they'll be
teaching marriage and uh he's pastor one
of the largest churches in america and
it's absolutely incredible communicator
she is as well they're a wonderful
couple good friends of sharon's of mine
and we're really excited to have them
teaching on marriage dr john i'll be
teaching on mental wellness we'll be
teaching on leadership on personal
growth on career with ken coleman uh
we'll be talking about money george
campbell will be there dave ramsey
rachel cruz will be there it's going to
be incredible christina alice will be
there and listen it's all day long and
you will leave smart
that's why we call it smart conference
neat name huh
right on the nose just like the dave
ramsey show like yeah like well hey
you're gonna leave tired too because if
you do anything hard anything worth the
value you're gonna leave tired so just
come ready to rock and roll i mean if
you went to a concert that lasted all
day long you'd be tired that's right you
know so i mean that that's what
and this is this is
world-class communication from the stage
world-class thought leaders you will not
be bored
you will feel like you've gone up to a
water fountain to get a drink and
somebody turned on a fire hose but you
gotta come this thing is life-changing
it's transformative tickets are only 39
or at least they start at that vips are
of course a lot more than
dot
that
slash events smart conference october
22nd in
dallas the big d
where john deloney will be uh one week
from wednesday on april the 27th to a
book signing there at the barnes noble
make sure you make plans to be there one
week from tomorrow also guys we're
getting ready to do a financial literacy
theme hour about saving for college
paying for college about scholarships
about going to college debt free if you
have a question in that area go to
ramseysolutions.com ask put college in
the subject line david is in montgomery
alabama hi david welcome to the ramsay
show
good afternoon gentlemen how you guys
doing today better than we deserve
what's up
fantastic so so i'm looking into uh
long-term care insurance for my wife
she's 55 actually we're both 55 so we
probably need to wait another five years
is usually recommend 60. but
understanding that my question is when
do i consider her self-insured as i
think we're kind of on the cut line for
considering ourselves shelf
self-insurance or needing long-term care
yeah
um
well it's self-insured always means you
can take the hit for the expense
without disrupting the whole plan
okay so let's kind of walk that through
the average nursing home stay in america
is two and a half years
typically
the typical scenario is
uh 75 percent of the ladies outlive
their husbands
and so the typical scenario is papa goes
into the nursing home
burns through 300 grand and if that was
the entire nest egg he cracks and
scrambles the nest egg
and um scrambled eggs and
dies and leaves mama with nothing
okay so we obviously don't want that so
if your entire net worth is 300 grand
you you can't do that you have to have
uh good long-term care insurance if your
entire net worth is 10 million dollars
you can write a 300 000 check and not
blink so if the average nursing home
stay is two and a half years and the
average cost is around 100 000 a year
then that's 250 to 300 000 bucks is your
typical exposure could it be more yeah
it could be but it probably won't be and
you can do in-home care even cheaper
than that and maybe get better quality
care depending on the type of issue that
you're dealing with uh in terms of
caring for the individuals so
uh all that to say if you can take a 300
000 hit and and the person that's left
keep rolling
then you're okay so if you've got a
million bucks
and they're left with 700 are you okay
yeah probably okay that makes sense yeah
probably so what's your net worth
uh 900 yeah well actually probably one
1.1 but yeah 900 yeah and it'll double
yeah have you got it invested well good
mutual funds oh yeah absolutely and
you're 55 so when you're 62 that's gonna
be two million
okay and and when you are um
70 it's gonna be four million
yeah so between 60 and 70 between 60
years and 70 years you're gonna have
between two and five million dollars two
and eight million dollars uh you're
self-insured you're fine
as long as you set the investments up
where you can access them and then you
do
okay
but be ready to write the check
emotionally
and say that's why i've worked my whole
life is so i can take care of my sweetie
yep makes sense oh no she'll be i'll be
long dead before that happens to check
herself
he's part of the ramsey estate plan our
entire estate plan is predicated on me
dying first i'm a little worried
a little worried sharon has a plan here
i'm just saying we're the same freaking
age actually she's actually three or
four months older than me you should
probably not say that out loud well
that's okay i mean we've been married 40
years
we'll get through it but oh my gosh
i mean geez hey is there oh i have to
die first i don't it's just just because
i'd be useless without her that's right
hey if looking at life at um the total
net worth package is there any sort of
ratio that we should be careful of when
it comes to how much of our home
is makes up our net worth well in that
case you have to sell you know with that
discussion you have to if you said okay
i have a million dollar net worth and
900 000 of it's my home right uh you
can't pay for the nursing home right
well i sell in the house so yeah that's
a problem uh or you downsize it and go
get a condo or something whatever and
then you can pay for the nursing home
but you got to sell the house right not
saying you have to live homeless but you
got to sell the house because the key is
less about net worth and more can you
eat 300 000 can you write that check can
you write that check and still be okay
there you go all right and so if you had
a million three net worth with a million
dollar house and you wrote 300 check you
ain't okay you have no margin that's
right it's not okay so you're right
that's a good that's a good
clarification that you don't want it all
tied up in that or let's say you had a
whole bunch of real estate
uh and that was your whole net worth you
would plan on selling a couple of those
houses that's right you know you're
going to pop one of those rentals to be
able to pay for the thing and that's
just part of it yeah and so and you know
we pray the real estate market's hot
when this happens
so lack of liquidity but being able to
access mutual funds out of a retirement
plan that's after 59 and a half
you're you're certainly okay if that's
where they are so
not a problem at all
kevin is with us in salt lake city hi
kevin how are you
doing well how are you better than i
deserve how can i help
so i needed some advice um a neighbor of
ours okay it's a little background
my wife and i and our three boys have
been renting
uh a basement apartment for the last
five years um in that time my uh
income's
gone from below 30 000 to right now i'm
60 000. good
um so
um
our neighbors offered to sell us their
house they're gonna move
um but it's so i mean it's way out of
our price range but
it's i think i mean i think it's i think
they want to sell for like 5 000 or
thousand dollars
and
um
you know it's way out of your price
yeah
one time you can afford a half million
dollar house for sixty thousand dollar
income dude
yeah and that's my main question is like
um and maybe it's like a
get some encouragement question or maybe
some different viewpoint question
because
we're just looking at like all the
houses in our area and we have really
good rent right now i mean we don't want
to leave our current rent situation
very quickly because it's just you know
it's we're paying like only a thousand
dollars a month in rent that's a good
situation
so every every house in our neighborhood
and
in the county
it seems to be in that kind of price
range on average like five hundred
thousand or you know up there it's not
true do you think so no
the average the median house price of
salt lake city is not a half million
dollars
nope
yeah about three and a quarter about
three and a quarter
three and a quarter yeah you can go look
it up that's the median house price yeah
so um or maybe in the tiny corner of
here's the thing here's the thing
i don't care where you live
salt lake city or california or
manhattan you don't get a pass on math
math still works in those areas so
you've still got to buy something on a
15-year fixed where the payment is no
more than a fourth of your take-home pay
after you're debt-free and after you
have your emergency fund in place dude
you're not ready to buy this house next
door i'm sorry keep renting this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr chondaloni ramsay personality open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five we'll talk to you
about your life and your money thank you
for
joining us we'll talk to you about how
to create amazing relationships we'll
talk to you about doing work you love
it's a free call here at rams at the
ramsey show thank you for joining us
ellie's with us in kansas city hi ellie
welcome to the ramsay show
right thanks for having me
good how can we help
um okay so we have my husband and i have
a stream of income that i'm not
really sure how to handle we have two
foster kids
that we foster outside of the foster
care system it was a kinship foster and
their grandparents
essentially pay us
to do so
which isn't why we
are doing it but
so we have this flow of money coming in
and i just am not really sure how to
handle it it's part of your income
okay so should i when you do your budget
you have your income at the top of the
page and you give every dollar of your
income
a a name
okay it's as if you had a part-time job
okay that's what i was going to ask so i
should uh
so it'd be like i'm self-employed so i
would want to like pay taxes on it like
quarterly and stuff uh yeah yeah if
you're you're going to claim it as
income they're going to claim it as an
expense
then yeah you would need to set aside a
fourth evidence taxes
and then and then you put the rest of it
in your budget
and you work it period it's not it's not
different money because it's for the
kids because you're going to pay for the
kids stuff anyway
and and what you what you do to feed the
kids or clothe the kids or
whatever expenses you have associated
with the kids during the time you're
fostering them is you're going to do
regardless of their money
you'll do it if it's more money than you
get you'll do it if it's less money than
you get you're going to do it you're
going to pay the light bill because they
stay in the house you're going to pay
the food bill because they stay in the
house you're going to pay the water bill
because they stay in the house
so you don't child supports the same way
it's not holy it isn't set to the side
and separate it's for supporting the
child and by the way you almost always
spend more on kids than you receive in a
situation like this
ellie are you all designated guardians
of these kids
uh right now we're um
we have temporary custody and we're
actually in the process of adoption okay
all right good
my fear is these these off-book deals
with kids can get real real messy real
fast yeah it's so good good for you that
makes me happy they all go through the
official process there
yes yes we are and so i mean the
grandparents want to still
be involved and provide but that's how
they feel they can because they can't
physically care for them so they want to
provide that way
so it should go
we have a separate account for them
should we just go straight in
straight into everything else yeah i
wouldn't have a separate account there's
no need
yeah if you had your own if they were
your own children you wouldn't have a
separate account you would just make
sure they had food and clothing and
shelter
right i just wasn't sure if this was
like if it should be taxable or not
taxable because it's not uh
i don't know if this is a a gift to you
or if this is an income to you as far as
taxes because it feels weird being paid
to do this because we would
we weren't we aren't doing it
how much are they giving you
um
they're giving us
750 twice a month
um
because i think that matches what that's
cycling that you would get in the foster
care system that the government gives i
think
so yeah 1500 a month
okay they are going to have a gift tax
on it
if they consider that a gift
are they do you know if they're yeah are
they writing this off their taxes are
they doing this just out of the no as
far as i know they are not okay
okay
well an individual can give another
individual fifteen thousand dollars this
year
okay
okay sixteen thousand dollars i'm sorry
in 2022.
um and that's eighteen thousand fifteen
hundred is eighteen thousand
so um
uh you know if they don't report it it's
probably never going to come up but
technically if they got audited they
could pay gift tax on two thousand bucks
if this is a gift if it is a gift to you
so i could just give you some money
i could give you ten thousand dollars
okay and there's no gift tax on that and
there's no income tax on that if however
i'm paying you for a service then that's
an income that you would pay income tax
on
and so i think we need to have a
determination here
that you know made by you and by them
that this is not payment that this is a
gift
you probably want to get that in writing
okay and then that would be figured out
we are giving you a gift and because
you're being so kind to our children
they're not paying you for child care
services yeah if they're paying you then
it becomes taxable
if they're giving it to you as a gift
it's not taxable so i would probably get
a letter from them stating that this is
a gift
and then i would not pay taxes on it but
as far as
i would not pay taxes on it because i
think that's really what it is i think
that's the spirit of the thing
right so
do you know if that letter has to come
with every every no it needs to come
once it needs to come once a year yeah
and hopefully it's only going to come
once because you're going to get the
adoption done
right and if you adopt these kids are
they still planning on giving you that
gift
i think so because i think that's
they still want to contribute because
i'm sure but
so if your grandparents get if i give my
grandkids if i give my my kids uh ten
thousand dollars for for my grandkids
it's not taxable
it's a gift
and if you've adopted these kids that's
the grandparents giving money to their
parents
right
okay okay so
for the adoptions finalized yeah before
the before it's fine i would want a gift
letter from them
and since they're not blood relatives
i'd want a couple of gift letters from
them and you can check with the tax
professional on exactly what the wording
would need to be
but um just we're going to give you a
gift of
um
and honestly i would reduce it to 16 000
a year let's make it easy for everything
so that nobody gets so they don't get
caught later with a gift tax i don't
want to get hammered
um that's simple but i wouldn't mess
with it so um but it's up to y'all what
you want to do but i'm just trying to
keep everything real clean i don't want
the irs in your life later because
everyone here is doing such a noble
thing you're taking care of some kids
whose parents went awol the grandparents
are taking care of kids that they love
but are not physically able and by
helping you take care of those kids
everybody in this story is a hero i also
don't want something i want is the irs
getting involved in a hero well i don't
want
some weird cousin or brother and sister
or child of these
great grandparents
um circling up and saying hey for the
last 15 years they've given you all this
and that was our money i'd want some
some sort of
writing down here yeah it wouldn't hurt
and they're allowed to do but listen
they do what they want their money
there's not anything that could be done
about it legally honestly
but it's just to be a good thing it'd be
good thing for everybody to have
communication just hey write me a letter
that says this is a gift to the children
and if i were you uh tell advise them
tell me talk to a financial person that
advises that they limit it to 16 000 a
year
um and so
because as you said you would do it
either way and
or if you want to get really technical
about it and uh nuanced uh
right um
three of the 750
four of the 750 dollar checks uh to uh
one of you you or your husband and write
the rest of them to the other one and
because they're allowed to give you
sixteen thousand give your husband two
thousand and then you still got the
whole eighteen thousand there so you get
real technical that's another way to do
it but if they're writing the check to
both of you
they're gonna go over at 18 grand so all
that to say anyway that's what we're
doing
all right yeah it's a wonderful story
though how
it just makes me think man have we have
we made it too complicated just help
each other out
yes it's so absurd man yes we have
it's called the irs it's called congress
got a messy situation death that we're
not gonna need them
that's so strange they're scared to
death that they're not gonna be relevant
they're the island of misfit toys but
they're not and they're not relevant but
but they're scared to death and so they
keep passing laws and
i mean the the the volumes
of regulations
that you have to know today we have two
grandparents here that just want to
bless their kids and they physically
can't care for these kids but they love
this advice and these people are these
foster parents are coming taking care of
them and everybody's good everybody's a
hero in this story
and yet we have to figure out some
stupid little
sightings gymnastics tricked him that's
the world we live in
if i had somebody working for me like
people in congress i'd say you're fired
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
family
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today nick and connor are with
us in lubbock texas says on my screen
you guys are debt-free congratulations
thank you thank you how are y'all better
than we deserve how much have you paid
off
bit off 126 000 way to go how long did
this take
just over five years
cool and your range of income during
that time
we started off around 33
and last year we ended up with 73. whoa
what do y'all do for a living
i am a
landscape crew leader
and um i am currently a stay-at-home mom
but i've had a couple of jobs in between
there
i worked as a cna and then i worked as a
research aide and a lab tech so very
cool what kind of debt was the 126 000
everything
we had student loans we had car loans we
had um
a loan for a bed
we had store credit cards i had a dirt
bike loan
so y'all are freaking normal
yeah
how old are you guys
i am 34 and 29 okay and so you were 24
and 29 when you started this journey
what was the wake up call and what
started you on this journey
well we had um
i was in school i'm actually an lcu grad
yeah dude
oh yeah john you were my dean of
students my first stint in school no i
wasn't was i really
yeah 2005. oh and look
that's fantastic man
and he turned out john
you made it nick way to go man you made
it
yeah we're both actually lcu grads oh
that's fantastic
yeah
but um
we left you a legacy of things to pay
off
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
so we had we had two vehicles that
both needed significant repairs and we
couldn't afford to repair them so we but
we could afford the new payment
and then
we actually
paymented ourselves that have been able
to pay rent and moved into a free rent
house that my parents owned
and then shortly after that we were
sitting at a church that we used to go
to
and they gave a present a presentation
basically advertising for the fpu class
that next year and showed that
a lar
a group of people paid off like
somewhere it was something ridiculous
like two million dollars paid off in
debt and yeah like they're they're
nine in their nine weeks or whatever the
groups that they had done they'd paid
off
so much money and we looked at each
other and we're like okay we really need
to get into this
we're drowning
so cool so we took that class and then
ended up moving churches and we became
coordinators and um
the rest is history wow so don john's
been your dean of students i've been
your dean of students i mean this is
yeah they clearly listen to you more
than they listen to me but that's well i
got them in no doubt that's that's
exactly right hey so what was the best
marriage spat y'all had
you know we were talking about that last
night and
really the hard part for us was just
doing the actual paper budget we never
really had any hard hard spats it was
just making the numbers work when we had
to adjust categories and
you know using calculators to get
everything to total up properly and we
just get frustrated and it's hard being
a crew leader out there rolling up in a
used car that needs some repairs and not
some fancy new truck that you can go get
off a lot right i mean you've you've had
people looking at you funny for the last
few years well i work for a company that
actually provides a work vehicle
that's great and and so we actually sold
both the vehicles that we had loans on
and um
so they're done we we actually have a
we we bought a used minivan a couple
years ago paid in cash
that's how you know you're in it brother
when you buy a used minivan you're in
2004
there you go
but it was in great condition when we
got it
i love it way to go
yeah that's good that's good you might
be an fpu if your van's older than your
wife
that's good guys i like it very well
done this is good congratulations
because i mean on 33 000 a year you
start this journey that's serious
yes sir and you bust through 126 you
sell the cars off you keep raising your
income double keep scratching and
clawing keep scratching and clawing and
hustling grind and you push your way all
the way through for five freaking years
this is this is hero stuff right here
you guys are incredible thank you for
being coordinators yes sir well the the
caveat to the five years is we actually
only did active debt payoff in about 22
months
yeah we kept we had two kids along the
way we cash flowed the last semester of
my life's college
and then we saved up for nursing school
and uh wow
that didn't end up coming through and so
we used that money that we had saved for
nursing school to put a big
big bump on the student loans and then
we had a
a small inheritance that helped us get
over the finish line wow
way to go guys guys are awesome way to
go thank you good journey representing
the 806 and the shops way to go oh yeah
oh yeah
good job all right now you're a
coordinator you've stuck with it you
pushed all the way through
you're a young family 100 debt free when
someone comes into your class and says
what do you have to do what's the secret
to getting out of debt what do you tell
them
communication for sure
um you just have to communicate
everything it's
and budget i mean obviously you can't do
this without a budget but um
we had a lot a lot of conversations last
night but one of the things that we said
was you know communicating our
we figured out last night how horrible
at communicating we were before we
started doing fpu and
just since finishing everything our
communication is so much better
and then i've got to say you know just
perseverance and grit because this has
been a
very long journey there have been
multiple nights doing budget meetings
where i was just both of us would be
tired of it you know usually at separate
times but then we would pull each other
through
and it was it was hard yeah yeah well
i'm proud of you guys very well done
you're heroes we've got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you how ordinary
people build extraordinary wealth how
you can too uh and uh since you're uh
been uh under the tutelage of dr john
dolone we're gonna send you a copy of
his brand new book own your past change
your future as well
so you're going to get one from each of
us and uh predicting that his will be a
best seller by this time next week when
we get the lists out and we find out
what happened with it but uh i'm sure
it'll be a bestseller of some sort proud
of you guys nick and connor way to go
way to go you guys very well done nick
and connor lubbock texas 126 000 paid
off in five years making 33-73
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that scream was five years of doing yard
work in the heat in west texas and
saying i'm done with this
yeah in west texas that's real heat a
lot of dust that's a lot of dirt hey
there's something about
there's something about starting this
process making thirty three thousand
dollars as a combined household income
that's great man yeah i mean that's
that's real that's half the national
average that's thirty three thousand
that's that's tough man and uh like
that's saying i know we got a 126
thousand dollar problem here we gotta
start somewhere let's start here
like what better time game on it yeah
it's not like you can see it and go oh
this is gonna be easy no
yeah
we'll be able to do this in about eight
months that's a big hole in the little
shovel the whole ratio right there sucks
yep i mean that was a little bitty
shovel a great big hole that's right and
they kept pushing kept pushing through
and uh it's real and then and during the
time double overdoubles his income
household
how often i feel like that happens every
time
people get intentional and then they get
maniacal and then all of a sudden
their workplace recognizes that they're
they're showing up more and putting more
in and they're more passionate and more
driven and all of a sudden man it just
tells you that um we don't use all of
our brain and we don't use all of our
income earning potential yeah until
there's a reason yep and then we go i
need some more money yeah and you go get
some more money and it's just amazing
thing you know i mean it's like we go
work extra we take a better job you look
up and go these people don't pay me
enough you know and you get a better job
and there's all kinds of things happen
but almost every debt free screen the
income went up during the debt-free
journey yeah and um
for
multitude of different reasons but it
generally does you're exactly right i
love it
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books thanks to the folks in the
booth james ben kelly doing a great job
in there zach this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john dolone
ramsey personality best-selling author
host of the dr john belloni show is my
co-host today today is launch day for
his brand new best-selling book own your
past change your future a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and mental wellness
we are of course taking calls on any of
those subjects as well as
people wanting to talk about doing work
that they love or how to get wealth
built or generosity money questions
we're here to help you the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five starting this hour is charlie
in dallas hi charlie welcome to the
ramsey show
hey dave thank you for taking my call
and uh dr john good luck on your book
launch thank you good man
thank you
um so i've been listening to you on and
off for a few years
and i finally realized i cannot out earn
my spending and i really want to reduce
risk while income is good
and i want to do it fast and i think i
finally understand the gazelle intensity
feeling
um but i'm afraid my wife isn't quite
feeling the same way
um i've kind of come up with a plan and
she's not 100 behind it um what's your
plan
35
well we owe 35 000 in back taxes um from
as far back as 2015.
i owe 14-7 this year
we have 12 000 on both of our cars
12 000 each
and
i want to basically sell my car and
throw everything we have the taxes
um and i think that we can be done
actually in the next three to four
months how did you tell her this plan
well we started
about january is when i really got
serious and i kind of just it would take
take take
dave back to the like you sat down how
did you announce this plan
i i've been asking her multiple times to
kind of sit down with me and help me
figure out how to
create more room in the budget
um and then finally we did that and she
got behind it and now you know i i
finally kind of encouraged her i was
like you know i think you can
you have some really good ideas usually
when it comes to saving money and
you know you're you're really helpful in
all these ways and i think that we can
just get on the same page you know
basically listening to you guys that one
i think our relationship will get a lot
better i think that we'll really make
some headway here um i tried to try to
try to tell her that i really needed her
help
um and
you know from from my understanding or
the way i feel is i feel like she's just
a little bit worried and i don't know if
it has to do with
past family stuff with her family and
money or how long have you all been
married with money
seven years almost how many jobs have
you had while you were married
this one
how many plans how many different plans
have you come up with while you were
married
well and that is to be fair and it's
never been to pay off the debt
you know we make
we make enough money we we can do this
we can do that because i have a new idea
every 20 minutes
and my wife is always like you're
scheming and scamming again
and it sounds like you were getting that
speech yes
pretty much
have you tried this this conversation
because you came at your wife with a
math problem and you came with her
at her with an algorithm if we do this
and this and this then here's the result
everything's great
and she's heard that before
another way to have this conversation is
to sit down one night over a meal and
hold their hands and say
i am terrified we're not safe
and i feel scared we owe the freaking
kgb 35 000. 35 grand we have two two
cars that we can't afford we have a
house that we can't afford we're not
getting tracked terrified we're not
getting traction i'm afraid we're going
to be old and living on social
insecurity
if it's even there
that's a different conversation than
well honey
cue up the carnival music i got a new
one right that's a totally different
conversation
and i have been very excited about this
yes
um
hey you're talking to two guys who get
excited you know i mean you know
it's a good thing but what it amounts to
is you have a set of information that
has informed your emotions that there's
hope
she doesn't have that information yet
and her hope button has not been pushed
yet because you've got a head start on
her you've been listening to the show
you've been listening to other people do
debt-free screams you've got you've got
a legitimate information that has you in
a different place than you than that and
so you know i run into that sometimes
here in the business in leadership
sometimes somebody will come in and sit
down and they go okay here's what we're
going to do and this person we have to
this person here uh you know they're not
going to make it we're going to let them
go and i'm like
stop the train junior you know you got
to catch me up you've been working on
this for a month you gave me 35 seconds
so you got to spend a minute here
catching me up
to where i can join you in this or i'm
about to put a quash on your idea and so
i play the wife in that case in your
world but because i don't have the same
set of information or emotions that they
do from having dealt with
this person goofing off or whatever
they've been doing inside the business
here that they're trying to lead and so
i if they catch me up with those
emotions i might get on board or i might
have another idea but we got to get her
you know so it's
number one we got to get her caught up
and just go i think it's a real good
thing to go listen
i don't have all this figured out and
i'm a wee bit excited
about this because for the first time i
got some hope
and i was previously terrified and i'm
afraid if we don't do something that is
way different than what we've been doing
we're going to keep doing what we've
been doing and that's not going to work
and here's another
number two
i've thrown a lot of hacks at you over
the last few years a lot of schemes and
ways to cut corners my plans don't work
i found the guys who playing that does
work for millions of people would you be
willing to do his plan with me or would
you be willing to look at that plan in
detail with me and see what you think of
it
that'd be okay too coming at her with
humility let her get caught up with um
that
uh yeah because
you know at least you didn't say i'm
gonna sell your car yeah
i knew that wasn't an option yeah but
you were gentle hey you were close
though cause you were like you know you
got great ideas you would really look
good in a uniform if you're out working
you got close man if you were a nurse
you would be making some money
it let her she'll get there she'll get
there when she looks in the eyes of a
man who says okay i've had all the
plants in the world i've tried and this
is me taking a knee and saying my
schemes didn't work but i think this
will work and it's not my plan it's not
my plan and i'm excited about it and
would you look at it with me we do it
with me yeah and um i tell you what
we're gonna help you with this um would
you go through a couple of these would
you look through a couple of these
videos with me we're going to put you
into ramsey plus as a gift
and that'll put you into financial peace
university and give you access to the
every dollar plus budgeting system the
premium system and it's all very easy
when you do that but
it's kind of like um you hear some of
these debt-free screams they're like how
did you get your spouse on board well we
went to uh we drove to florida and had
to listen to you your podcast all the
way to florida
so it's like oh after that they were on
board who knew
it's like
i'm trapped in the dadgum car
but it's but it's it's it's they were
listening to dave and these other
callers not you in one of your schemes
again right yeah he's hearing somebody
pull up some debt-free screams on
youtube
and and watch them watch their body
language watch those people
watch them watch how light they feel how
the different how the
position of their shoulders is different
oh so beautiful
so beautiful it's called hope
man it's real it's very real
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
well we heard recently that the paw that
the paws on the student loans has been
extended again
why don't they just extend it
indefinitely that'd be interesting
no they're not going to do that
they're going to extend it
until the midterm elections that's
exactly either the midterm or right at
the beginning of the four year yeah
they're going to use it now this is no
longer about economics this is now about
politics total politics yeah
student loans shouldn't be a crushing
weight in your life you can be rid of
them with the right plan it's a perfect
time to work on your student loans since
they're not causing payments and
interest you can really crush the
principal this is not the time to ignore
it just because they told you to
instead you should go after it with
everything you got right now and get rid
of the student loan use this
wonderful respite from the interest to
get some freaking traction good time to
get into financial peace university good
time to do this this course will teach
you our proven plan to pay off your
student loans and all your debt within
just a few months or a couple years not
decades millions of people with every
type of income every amount of student
loans have done it with financial peace
university you can
and when you don't owe anything to
anyone
yeah you will never feel that weight
hanging over you again you don't even
realize how much you're carrying until
you're not carrying it anymore
start financial peace university for
free at ramseysolutions.com
fpu that's ramseysolutions.com
fpu
financial peace university
almost 10 million people have gone
through that class now
it has changed a lot of lives the
information their gods and grandma's
ways of handling money it'll rock your
world check it out at
ramseysolutions.com
kelly is with us kelly is in phoenix
arizona hi kelly welcome to the ramsey
show
hello
hey what's up
i got a question for you in regards to
a 401k
uh my employer offers and it is a roth
401k
so the question is
my
tax guy this year told me that i don't
qualify for the roth part because i make
over 75 000 a year not true
doesn't know what he's doing
you don't qualify for a roth ira
individual ira if you make too much
money but the roth 401k is available
regardless of income i do one
me too and we both make way
more than those limits
so it'd be better to keep it as a roth
versus the traditional 401k yeah bet
grows tax-free tax-free is better than
with taxes
right makes sense
well
i always thought the loss you know grew
you paid your taxes on what you put in
and and uh you didn't so much on what
you get out but he explained that you
put it in
um
it comes off let me just tell you you're
going to put into your 401k
the same amount whether it's a roth or a
traditional aren't you
correct
okay
so you did you went ahead and paid the
taxes on the portion you put in if it's
in a roth
and let me tell you how old are you
36. okay when you are 66
94 of what is in your account will be
growth
six percent will be what you put in
almost all of it is growth
when you get to your when you get to the
end game and you don't want the growth
to be taxed
or the best way i could tell you to
explain if there's four million dollars
in your account two million dollars in
your account
almost all of that is taxable or not
depending on whether you chose roth it's
this is really not a hard math problem
you simply do not want to pay taxes on
it dude well in the
i i can't think of no better endorsement
in in that this is what we do with our
money
yeah like this isn't a math problem
i'm 61
and it's a wrath
because i probably will never touch it
yeah it'll probably be left in an
inheritance i'll probably live out of
other money and i'll just let it
continue to grow tax-free until old dave
pushes up a daisy i mean that's that's
that's just let the puppy grow and so if
i'm 91 30 years from now i get tax-free
growth all that time and i don't have
rmd i don't have required minimum
distributions when i'm 70 and a half so
you just don't want to do this dude you
can do whatever you want get a new tax
cut you do whatever you want to do but
uh if your tax guy is telling you can't
do a roth 401k you need a new tax guy he
doesn't know what he's talking about
eddie's in philadelphia hey eddie
welcome to the ramsey
show hey dave doctor john honor speak
with you guys you too what's up
so my question to you is my i'm getting
married in about a month and a half and
my fiance
just started a very expensive master's
degree program but she also wants to be
a stay-at-home mom
i'm not sure how to handle this
well why are you waiting until a month
and a half before marriage to address
something this serious
well we have been addressing this um no
we haven't sounds like she has you
haven't
well we've both we this is has
definitely been a point of
i should say contention since we
um
we've been together for six years so
this master's program started two months
ago and we have had extensive
conversations about it
um but i didn't really want to be the
person to hold her back from doing it
especially before we were even engaged
so i kept my opinion to a minimum
because i didn't want to be that person
who held her back from her dreams um but
let me just tell you if you're if the
person you loves dream is really a
nightmare you should say something
i completely agree and
we have had um several conversations
with my parents
and her parents about
the situation and we're just not really
getting anywhere
what's the what's the program it's a
master's in nutrition degree okay and
what's what in her heart says why is
this experience
um well there were two questions there
um it's i'm not really sure why it's so
expensive but it costs about sixty
thousand dollars just for the tuition
after her scholarships
and it's uh
what's expensive because people will pay
it but go ahead right yeah it's
definitely one of the more expensive
institutions in the city
um and
yeah that's kind of where why does she
want why does she need this why does she
want to do this
well
the way she was raised there's always
been high value on education and
detaining getting that next degree
there are a lot of different reasons why
but she obviously doesn't want to let
her parents down she feels like she's a
very smart girl which she is
and
this will kind of be like a status
elevation thing and
it's a topic that is just very
interesting for her yeah those are her
reasons for one and two so
are you all taking out loans for this
thing you're paying for it in cash
so not yet that's kind of where the
contentions come into play because i've
sat down with her and tried to map out a
plan of okay who's paying for this
you know are your parents going to help
and am i kind of footing the bill for
the whole thing
and unfortunately her parents recently
had a split a divorce like two months
ago
so the aid from that side is now kind of
in a gray area we're not really sure if
they're going to help but
i don't really want to be put in a
situation where i just get hit with a
bill all right
so there's two nowhere dave and hop in
here there's two big issues here okay
issue number one is you're about to
marry somebody
and y'all have not been able to have
very basic
low-level
conflict agreement conversations
i cannot think of a bigger red flag
other than she's dating somebody else
because this will be a conversation
about what home we buy what neighborhood
what schools what kid this will go
you'll have this conversation a thousand
times
it just happens to be over a degree plan
and i personally and again dave may
disagree it's great i
if you have cash for this and you want
to get a master's degree to learn about
nutrition knock your lights out if you
can pay for it it's going to be a joint
decision it's something we're going to
do together and i'm going to use the
nutrition info for the kids great
if it's for a status symbol then you
might as well be buying a porsche that
you can't afford and you don't know how
anybody's gonna pay for it right this is
it the whole thing feels gross and then
you don't know who's gonna pay for it
this whole thing's a mess man and the
fact that you guys had to discuss it
with both your parents is a weird thing
you're about to get married you're
grown-ups
the whole yeah we're not married yet and
well
yeah
you're about to be you're way down close
to the altar to be having this
discussion this late and not be in
agreement on it you guys need to sit
down with an emergency session with a
marriage counselor today today today
today today this is this is this is like
stop them wedding type stuff this is
about communication less about the
degree not about the degree it's not
about disagree with the stupidity of the
degree which i do but that's a side
issue yeah the the issue is is that you
guys do not know how to have a
discussion without you ruining her
dreams let me just tell you after 40
years sharon ramsey has no trouble
ruining my dream thank god right if she
thinks that they're a nightmare
she has no trouble calling stupid butt
ideas stupid butt ideas because she
doesn't want to go down with me next
time i go do something
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today his brand new book on sale
today
own your past change your future a not
so complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness in the lobby
of ramsey solutions on the debt free
stage glenn is with us hey glenn how are
you man hi i'm good how are you better
than i deserve you're welcome where do
you live sir uh cherry hill new jersey
all right cool welcome to nashville
thank you and all the way here to do a
debt-free scream that's right i've been
waiting for this day for the last two
years well we're honored to have you sir
how much did you pay off uh a hundred
eighty two thousand two hundred seven
dollars
and how long did that take you sir uh 19
months
and your range of income during that
time i started at 135 000 and i'm
currently at 220 000. well there's a
nice job
what do you do for a living i'm a video
producer for a company in california
okay and you went just crazy how did you
double your income man um i have a great
manager who fights for me and my
teammates and i got two great uh pay
raises the second one being a promotion
wow good for you congrats you're awesome
obviously side hustles and yeah you're
obviously good at what you do and you
work your butt off too huh i did i do
good for you man so what kind of debt
was the 182 000 oh god uh
9000 was on a credit card
17 000 was on a stupid car
stupid butt car as you would say the
dumbest decision i've ever what was it
it was like oh my god i'm so embarrassed
it was a chevrolet camaro don't laugh oh
it's wonderful it's awful it's a
wonderful car to get messed up
it's a car for high school tight ends go
ahead yeah and then the rest uh just
over 150 000 of student loans so 58 000
on federal loans and just under a
hundred thousand with
navient whoa
whoa
you got rid of the evil naviance oh evil
man hundred 19 months man i mean you you
you have lived on nothing and worked all
the time yes this has been you've been
like completely game on yes
laser focus intensity these numbers are
amazing
you really you really have been on beans
and rice i'm so proud of you man what
got you so freaking fired up beans rice
and ramen i have to say i love ramen
okay all right all right
she loves you man this is good this is
good so what got this whole thing
started with you yeah um from 2015 to
2020 i was living in california
pretty expensive state and then this
little thing called the pandemic
happened and in march of 2020 uh my
company told everyone to work from home
and so
i had i
i got scared that um california was
banned out of out of state travel so i
booked a flight out of california and to
new jersey
and then um two weeks of work from home
turned into a month then it turned into
two then three
and uh eventually i'm still in new
jersey and i just got cleared to work
remotely luckily i travel a lot for my
work so they justified my working from
home
and um
from march to september i was still sort
of dave ramsey-ish i i wasn't paying
rent anymore and so i was like oh i had
all this income
and then my brother my younger brother
went on his own debt-free journey and
became debt-free in september of 2020
and when he became debt free i said oh
my gosh this is it it's my turn
and so i became really intense starting
september 2020 and the next month i flew
back to california i moved out all of my
stuff from my apartment that i was
living in
and that car that stupid car i sold it
took carmax gleefully i sold it it was
the best feeling it had been sitting
there it had been sitting there yeah oh
and i was paying for it you're using
public transportation in jersey
i i i had no car i still don't have a
car i've been sharing a car with my
parents and um i've been biking to the
gym i really lived on nothing
and i lived luckily i lived rent free
with my parents as well so they're
they've been great and you make 20 000 a
year so now you can go buy whatever you
want to that's right i love it but i'm
going to pay for cash absolutely i know
i know and i know you are i know you're
done after this you're definitely done
for life right when you
when you're making 220 grand and you
have to say
uh hey hey mom can i borrow the car to
go to the mall yeah then you know i'm
never doing this again i i wanted all my
income to go to my debt so i got i
didn't have a car so that meant no gas
payment no insurance payment i had the
privilege of living rent free i lived
bare bones
i followed your plan and so from
september to
last
last march
i just worked my butt off and not only
did i work my main job i worked side
hustles i i had a
my mom's friends were ordering cakes for
me i i baked in 2020 i made three
thousand dollars baking i i door dashed
in 2021 um i did video editing side
hustles i put myself on fiverr facebook
marketplace um
uh craigslist um my friends referred me
to jobs and yeah that's how i made extra
income as well on top of my regular all
the time all the time yeah so okay now
you're completely free
way to go thank you
i'm so proud of you man thank you so
what's the next step for you
now that you're free okay get your own
place now i'm gonna yeah i'm gonna get
my own place obviously save three to six
months of expenses i'm still on the baby
steps plan i have the financial peace
app and i follow that religiously so i
love it
well you're an incredible young man how
old are you 33 wow how's it feel to be
free
oh my gosh
i've never been to prison but i feel
like it's like getting out of prison
that's what it feels like and i've never
had cancer but i feel like it's like
listening to your doctor say like you're
cancer-free like it was like financial
cancer
yeah wow
have you had the moment where the
paycheck deposits
and
you don't have any other bills to pay
you keep it all
well
that technically happened uh on the 15th
of this month april but i actually owed
taxes
so april 30th will be my first one where
i have no literally no payments and i
get to keep all of it so i'm so excited
for for that uh next friday yeah wow
that's so good for you man
congratulations thank you very very
powerful very well done okay your little
brother did it and that got you going uh
and he was doing ramsay stuff huh yeah
he's an avid listener of yours uh he was
listening before i was okay yeah and
that guy
i got you turned on and plus if your
little brother does it that's kind of
like calling you out
i mean it's like yeah game on so you got
you got to do it you can't let a little
brother beat you
right yeah he's younger than me but i
feel like i follow in his footsteps like
he got into weightlifting then i got
into weightlifting he got into working
out we were both like chubby kids in
high school and he started lifting then
i started lifting he got out of debt and
i got up that even though i was i'm
older i i follow his footsteps i love it
that's good good stuff man well done
brother well done so proud of you well
we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you how ordinary people
built extraordinary wealth now you can
too i think you're definitely going to
be a millionaire not any question in my
mind and uh your parents got to be proud
of you who were your biggest
cheerleaders as you went along uh
definitely my parents um they
every time i paid off a loan i would
show them my naviance app like hey my
this loans paid off and i would show
them my financial peace app
um
uh my brother kevin and his fiancee
melissa um
and also my friends uh nadia carissa
katie susan yeah
hey what was a hundred and fifty
thousand dollar degree in
um oh my gosh i a useless communications
degree and a film minor
i went to a very expensive private
university gotcha okay i don't even
wanna say their name just because it's
okay that's fair we don't want to
advertise for him no okay that's right
that's right yeah well done glenn good
work brother so proud of you good stuff
man and all the way from jersey to do
your debt-free scream here in tennessee
very very very well done good stuff
as i said we got a copy of those books
for you we'll get those out to you glenn
from cherry hill new jersey 182
thousand dollars paid off in 19
months
all he did was sell everything and have
no anything that cost him anything he
got rid of it no more payments no more
insurance no more tax no more taxes
nothing no more nothing and got rid of
everything making 135 all the way up to
220 took every job he could get his
hands on that's gazelle intensity boys
and girls this is how it's done count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one i'm dead
[Applause]
that's how it's done right there i love
it
yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes excellent
job man
powerful i do not want to get between
that guy and a goal
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's 20 million
137 000 paid off so far this year with
debt free screams alone a lot of lives
changed dave pretty incredible so proud
of all of you you people out there doing
it man you're the heroes we're so
honored to walk with you as a gift we're
so honored to get to talk to you to get
to meet you
this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day ezra 10 4 rise
up this matter is in your hands
we will support you so take courage and
do it
babe ruth said yesterday's home runs
don't win today's games our question of
the day comes from blinds.com find out
for yourself why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible deal all right today's
question comes from kristin in new york
i'm a 25 year old college graduate and
i'm employed full-time i grew up in a
very affluent family during adolescence
it was great but moving into adulthood
i've realized that everything i have is
because of my parents and their
generosity
my parents literally pay for everything
gas food clothes phone insurance i have
no idea how to manage my finances or
grow my wealth in the next year i want
to buy my own home and set myself up for
a successful future i want to be able to
provide a future family with everything
my parents provided to me
where should i begin
it's a great ques i would tell you
you've already begun because you
recognized it the number of people who
are 35 or 40 who haven't put this
together yet is staggering so good for
you for even recognizing whoa
um i'm out on an island here and i don't
even know how i got here
i love it yeah um i it's a little
overstated everything you have is not
because your parents you graduated from
college and you're employed full-time so
the last batch of food that went in the
refrigerator you went to the grocery
store and bought
if you're employed full-time unless you
live with your mom or unless they're
just having things delivered or whatever
wow
well i would stop any income coming from
your parents you're 25 yeah you need to
financially separate from them
would you if you haven't already but i
kind of since she has she just means
that they they set her up as well no i
think that i think she's probably still
getting you think they're still buying
her gas yeah um i i what would you do
she says my parents literally pay for
everything yeah still i guess yeah oh
stop that would you do think about the
conversation of sitting down with your
mom or your dad whoever runs the money
and saying
oh it's time for me to start learning
the lessons
what are the what are the principles and
the rules by which you steward and
manage your money because i want to
learn those
i wonder if that'd be a a good gate and
i guess that the response is i don't
worry about we're taking care of you
then you know that that's not going to
be a good source of wisdom and
information but they might sit down and
say i'd love to teach you
i don't know it's probably where i would
start yeah i would do that i jump into
financial peace university and i think
you need a 90-day plan to be completely
financially on your own you're 25 and
you're full-time employed yeah
i love that idea too like start at the
baby steps yeah and you're going to be
able to expedite them but learn the
principles but go ahead and learn how to
handle money learn how to do a budget
learn how to pay your light bill um and
you know
you're you're
but um you're being treated like you're
12 right not like you're 25.
and so in that sense your mom and dad
are a little off kilter i bet there's
some heavy not strings i bet there are
some ropes attached to these
relationships it might be or it might be
they're just
getting tremendous personal satisfaction
out of providing everything without
thinking about the harm that it is doing
because
uh you haven't got any uh muscle tone
but to say if i lift all the weights
from my son then he never feels the
pressure of the bar which is fine but he
never grows any muscle either yeah
and so
um
let's pretend that this is an absolute
best case scenario and there are no
ropes or strings attached and your dad
and mom are simply just very sweet and
very generous people and that's an
absolute best case scenario and they're
not really drawing some kind of sick
psychological income from doing all of
this okay that's an absolute best case
scenario they're just sweet generous
people
in which case
somebody in this equation in this story
needs to wake up and go you're an adult
and that's going to be you see what
she's done and that's going to be you
sitting down with mom and dad and going
uh guys i'm going to go through this
class financial peace university i'd
love some input from you guys on how i
can be as good as you are someday um and
we need to develop a plan where
i am financially uh
sustaining myself
that we sever the ties and you quit
giving money you quit paying for
anything
because really within 90 if if you got a
reasonably good job you should be able
to pay your own freaking bills
absolutely
and part of wealth management and
legacy management is sitting down with
mom and dad when you're 25 and you have
your own job and you're all grown up is
saying
where are the wills and what happens
when and who's where's the trust and who
runs this stuff and being able to learn
you've i've learned from you you you
have some hard conversations with your
kids and family yeah yeah um
but they're not they're not
well yeah the the good news is they may
not be there
i i don't know i mean this is just
there's so much
um this is so mushy and soft
um
in a bad way there's no muscle tone yeah
it's everything's atrophying so yeah you
kristen you got to call this off
it has to end
and you got to do it as gently and
kindly and firmly
as you can you're not trying to be
disrespectful it's been a wonderful
thing and i'm very grateful for what all
you've done and uh well you're just not
grateful no i'm very grateful but i'm
also 25.
i'm like grown and stuff
and stuff
so i need i'm going to start paying my
own light bill and uh surely to god
their electric bill is her electric bill
is not in their name
but maybe they bought her a house and
they just went ahead and have their name
on the deed of the house and they pay
the bills she may not be she may be
living with them yeah no
i want to buy my own home
she may you may need to get an apartment
that's your first step and learn to live
on your own learn to buy your groceries
learn to pay your bills learn to set the
electric bill up on the draft on your
checking account learn to do these kinds
of things um and
you know get all that done before you
buy a home i bet she's still living at
home yeah that's what's going on so you
need to make plans to move out too
asap
asap
as soon as possible because fun things
will happen to your
uh psychological emotional spiritual
development
when you're on your own
um
i mean i noticed that when our kids were
no longer under our umbrella that they
walked different absolutely there's a
dignity to
being your own person and you probably
noticed they skinned their knees a few
times and twisted an ankle that's part
of walking on your own right yeah they
blew a tire and they figured it out
that's right you know i don't mind
helping them but they figured it out
and uh you're not you're not 12 right
you're 25. it's a different thing so
it's good it's a good discussion
so hey thanks for thinking this is the
first uh reverse debt snowball i've
heard you need to take fpu so you can
learn how to deal the money the other
way yeah that's right you learn how to
handle all this money you got don't know
what to do with it heather's in los
angeles hi heather welcome to the ramsay
show
hi thank you for taking my call i have
to say this is an honor i've listened to
you since i was a teenager wow thank you
how can we help you for me
my husband and i are expecting and also
looking to move out of state
here uh in the next
six months or so when does the baby do
november the beginning of november and
you want to move right as the baby is
due
i know we're crazy we're looking to move
maybe around september
to arizona so hoping to miss
the really hot part but move and stuff
before the baby comes
and you're going to move in the third
trimester
this is your first child isn't it
yeah and september's real real hot and
fixed
i know why the urgency
well we live in los angeles uh which i
feel like speaks for itself um we we
want to get the heck out of dodge if i'm
going to be completely honest go now
what about in 30 days
well my husband uh
has not been approved to work remotely
yet and so that's part of what we're
waiting for also i'm a swim instructor
so we're hoping that i can crank out a
bunch of swim lessons make a ton of
money and then we can move after that um
my hope is to be a stay-at-home mom if
that's possible
um but we want to buy a house and so
i'm looking for some insight as to
whether or not you think
now with the economy is going to be the
right time we would have 10 percent to
put down uh which is not you're
debt-free i'd like
yes we are on baby step 3b if you're
buying a home financially and you're
debt-free and you put down a reasonable
down payment and your payment is no more
than a fourth of your income on a
15-year fixed that's okay
however
most people don't make really really
great decisions in their third trimester
and moving in your third trimester as a
father of three
sounds like a really
dangerous idea i might wait till january
yeah first of all december up to you
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
hey it's john deloni co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you